The joe rogan experience when we're
talking about Jeff Bezos before the show,
who's now the richest man
in human history. It's like,
it's inconceivable amount of money.
He's worth $105 billion. Right.
Which is just like,
what the fuck?
He's like the eighth biggest landowner
and United States. Do you know that?
He just buys. It's crazy and
I'm not stunned. Of course.
Not 300,000 acres of
Texas. Whoa. That's a lot.
That's a lot. Yeah. That's a
big slab. Yeah. I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure his DC home was either,
uh,
I feel like it was either a museum
or a hotel before. He was like,
make that shit my house. Now
I'm museum. They were like,
it's your house.
I wonder what he's like to hang out
with because there's a photo of him.
See if you could find this photo at Jamie.
There's a photo of Jeff Bezos from 1993
and he's got like a vinyl banner above
his desk that says amazon.com and it's
just him and his Janky little fucking
Ikea desk,
like bad kind of Chubby typing away.
She got some muscle in on jacked and
Tan and probably got a supermodel for
girlfriend. Does he know he's got a
wife for curricular? Yeah. Normal. Yeah.
She's an author. Yeah. How
long? I know I'll have, hmm.
He doesn't schedule morning meetings so
he could hang out with the kids. Really?
Yeah. Wow. I read all this stuff.
I wonder why he's going so hard.
You know when you hit 105 billion,
yeah.
You would think you'd go,
Eh, we're good. I know.
I think you just start really
collecting cause you're like,
cause you know when he
bought the Washington Post,
you know it's not like he's like,
I love journalism. He right.
Be Cool to own a newspaper.
You know what I mean?
Like what do you at that level
you're just like, I like waterfalls.
Are there any for sale or
something? You know, he's got,
Washington Post is one of the weird
ones where you get a link some,
they'll send you a link and you click
on it and it's a Washington Post article
and it says you obviously love great
journalists write sign up. Like fuck off.
They don't even give you the free reads.
I feel at times we'll give you 10 free.
I signed up after I, you know, I
kept clicking those. I was like,
I better sign up Washington Post. I feel
like click number one. They're like,
do you want to read this? You want to pay
or not? Yeah. I'm not a, I'm not paying.
Yeah. I mean I, I support
paying for journalism,
but I feel like they should
give us a taste. You know,
we should get a little taste.
It's tough to trust journalism these days.
It's tough to trust like how fucking
weird of your article is going to be.
That's true. It's true. Journalism is
tough. Uh, watching news has become,
man, I remember when it started
to skew to personality and taste.
Now it's like off the rails. It is off
the rails. That's where the money is.
I know, but it's like you were
totally just going with who,
like you're going to watch,
you can select,
what do I feel like leaning towards and
then you watch that Tucker Carlson or
you know, yeah, yeah. Rachel Maddow.
Yeah. There he is. That's that picture.
Oh my God. Isn't that crazy? Yes. He
looks nothing like that now. Yeah.
It's what 105 billion will do.
He's just sitting there
with that amazon.com banner.
I hope that's still hanging
somewhere in his house. Yeah,
he probably shoots loads on that thing.
What do you,
oh my God. Yeah. Crazy
that he started off.
I remember Amazon being a book thing.
Yeah.
I remember being a place to buy books
and I remember thinking, how weird,
look on an online bookstore.
Why wouldn't you just go to the bookstore
store where you could see the book,
right? Like, and all those books
are shut. She's like, they close.
It's only a few left.
Well,
I know a guy who got a deal with
amazon.com to publish a book.
It was like when Amazon started
publishing books and they blackballed him
because of this,
because he had had traditional outlet
deals before and you know his books would
be front and center in Barnes, noble,
and all these other different places.
He's a pretty popular author, but as soon
as he went to amazon.com they're like,
fuck you. And they just shut
them out. They shut him out
of all those stores. Yeah.
And I was like,
whoa.
Like there's like a weird book war
going on that I didn't know about.
They're both probably try.
I mean there's book,
people were trying to keep their business
model going and thriving, you know,
and he ends up doing it by threats is
never the way to go. Probably not. No.
I mean the best way to go is when Amazon
publishes a book that people actually
want to buy in your store. You dumped
foc short and your store. You know,
I hate about these uh, super
rich guys. They'll never,
they never in their interviews taught
have like the only one who will talk like
what it's like to ball at that level and
make it sound fun and like the things
you want to add is mark Cuban. I've
seen him in interviews and be like, I,
I got last shit.
And like knows that.
Like that's a genuine curiosity
for people. Like, how fun is that?
You have to seven 47th. He's like,
yeah man, it's pretty cool. Right?
And he talks about it,
but I saw this interview with gates and
this guy was asking all those questions.
He was like, you have to worry
about like when somebody asks you,
like when you ask for something that
someone's going to try to ask for more
because of your known wealth. He's like,
you know, my charity really is like,
just like dodging all those questions
of like the fun shit that everyone was.
He just kept going back to
his charity and we're like,
we know you're a fucking charitable guy.
Tell us what it's like to own six planes,
bro. Like what kind of Shit do you have?
You know,
he's just like this Zana do house.
It's like 70,000 square feet or
something. Well, he's got a house,
I think it's on Puget sound.
Um,
it's somewhere in the Seattle area.
Is Medina Medina or Medina says that
what it is, I think is what it's called.
It's so freaky. Look at that. It looks
like using the nod and ad blocker.
What'd he pulled up, which pull up 19
crazy facts about his house. Oh, okay.
$123 million,
disable your ad blocker so we can read it.
So we, um, we were in Seattle and there's
this a thing that's near a bridge,
um,
where you,
you go under this bridge
and they have this, uh,
these clear walls where you can see the
salmon swimming up the salmon ladders,
but they have everything set up with
these clear like glass walls so you can
watch it with, it's really
pretty bad ass. Yeah.
But the guy who was there who was the,
uh, you know, the guide of this thing,
who's explaining us,
you know,
how this works and which kind of salmon
you're looking at and the whole deal.
He was like,
you know,
my uncle worked on the Bill Gates' house
and starts talking about Bill Gates'
House and where Bill Gates
houses and where he lives.
And I remember thinking like,
how weird must've B,
if you're so rich that all everybody
wants to do is talk about like, Hey,
my friend worked on your heart, his home.
And I was like, well what's it like?
And he just starts
describing skill as well.
He has like some sort of a submarine
access and Casey's getting kidnapped.
Like someone's trying to jack them.
They can get in a submarine and shoot
out into the river. I'm like what?
Yeah I don't know even how much of that
is even true because this guy seemed
like he was missing a little piece of his
brain start really adding stuff to it.
Yeah. So I was thinking, I was like
how much of this is urban myth?
I know that they were reporting even like,
I don't know when that house was built
10 15 or whatever years ago that even
back then there was shit in his house
cause it was super high tech of like if
you walk in a room music would play and
as you left the room music would die
down and pick up in the next room. So
that you know, it had, which at the,
I think you could probably regular person
could probably do something like that
now.
But like that was unheard of.
I think you wore a pin him pin on and
that pen as you walked into different
rooms,
recognize that you were the person,
so he had specific colors that you liked.
So they'd be like backlighting that
was just like to be a, his kids,
like he's big on, uh, he's the one
that started that giving pledge,
which is like for billionaires to give
the overwhelming majority of their wealth
to charity so that you don't pass
on billions to your children.
Right. So his thing is like, I'm
going to leave my kids money,
but not like crazy man. It's that money,
which you're like, yeah, that's, you know,
I totally get the idea behind that.
But also like if you grew up with his,
you know,
you're his kid and you're
like, oh, there's, we got
lions or whatever, and then,
and then you're like, you know, you
grow up and you're like, I'm a whatever,
a photographer now, uh,
my dad left me $5 million,
but like $5 million is great.
It's great. But my thing is like,
it's such a step down
from what they're used to.
I feel even remotely bad for some fucking
kid who gets $5 million from his dad
feel bad. What I'm saying is that that
adjustment has to kick you in the balls.
I mean, the exposure that they've
had, the lifestyle is like, it's not,
it's unfathomable to us. Like we can't
even, it's beyond, they're just like a,
it's like being the,
the, a prince, you know,
it's like your dad's assault
and the Brunei, and then
he's like, well, go fuck him.
I mean, they're probably well adjusted.
I don't know why I assumed that,
but I think that like,
uh,
he and his wife seem like such reasonable
people that I bet they've, you know,
prepared them for, for, for what's coming.
[inaudible]
yeah.